un hélicoptère de l'armée ukrainienne de
système u 8 qui a explosé les
explications sans un petit peu selon les
sources il aurait été poussé en fait
lorsqu'il était au sol par un tir de
roquette
un peu plus tôt on avait entendu une
autre version il aurait été poussé au
niveau de sa part par un tir de sniper
il aurait un blessé le pilote n'a été
blessé et on aurait des témoins sur
place qu'on distille l'appareil aurait
été touché au moment du décollage on
doit montrer des photos qui montrent
hier aussi un appareil de type antonov
la continuité qui aurait été
partiellement détruit entre-temps dans
le mystère de la défense ukrainien a
lancé ce qu'ils appellent la deuxième
phase de l'opération de reconquête de la
ville de saint just et les troupes du
cayenne sont stationnés au pourtour de
la ville de ses lancers seulement
on peut penser a décidé d'encercler la
ville dans un dans un étau pour le
ravitaillement en amont en fait c'est
l'iran fort et bleu ciel intérieur donc
les milices qui est pour eux mais le
message de défense à terre que les
militaires sont touchantes strictes pour
éviter donc tout de toute victime civile